.
ASRA NOMANI, THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO THAT WAS NINA
JANKOWICZ WHO WE JUST TOLD YOU
THE HEAD OF THE MINISTRY OF
TRUTH AND ALREADY SHE IS BEING
SUED, BY THE WAY, THE STATES OF
MISSOURI AND LOUISIANA HAVE
FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST
OFFICIALS LIKE JANCO IT'S FOR A
TAX TO FREE SPEECH.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
REPEATED THE CALLED ON FACEBOOK
AND OTHER PLATFORMS TO CENSOR
OPINIONS THAT ARE CRITICAL OF
THEM.
ERIC SCHMIDT IS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF MISSOURI,
JOINS THE SUIT AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
TELL US WHY YOU ARE SUING.
>> LOOK, WE ARE FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST TWO OF THE MOST POWERFUL
AND CORRUPT INSTITUTIONS OUT
THERE, BIG GOVERNMENT AND
BIG TECH OR COLLUDING, WORKING
TOGETHER TO SUPPRESS SPEECH AND
THEY DO IT IN A COUPLE DIFFERENT
WAYS, TUCKER.
THEY ARE PULLED OVER THESE
SPECIAL PROTECTIONS LIKE SECTION
230, ALSO BEEN VERY OUTSPOKEN,
JEN PSAKI HAS TALKED ABOUT HOW
THEY ARE FLAGGING POSTS IN JULY
OF LAST YEAR, FLAGGING POST FOR
FACEBOOK AS DISINFORMATION, SO
THEY ARE WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
THEM, WE KNOW THAT AND NOW THIS
NEWEST ORWELLIAN CHAPTER, THIS
DYSTOPIAN CHAPTER OF THE
MINISTRY OF TRUTH, YOU HAVE
MARY POPPINS IN CHARGE OF THIS
THING I GUESS NOW AND THAT WOULD
BE LIKE PUTTING, BY THE WAY,
CRUELLA DE VIL IN CHARGE OF
MANAGING AN ANIMAL SHELTER, IT'S
A TOTAL DISASTER, OKAY, THESE
FOLKS ARE NUTS, THEY ARE INTENT
ON SUPPRESSING SPEECH THAT THEY
DON'T LIKE, CALLING IT
DISINFORMATION, MISINFORMATION,
SO WE ARE FILING A LAWSUIT AND
TUCKER, YOU TALK ABOUT THIS ALL
THE TIME, THE REALITY IS
INDIVIDUALS HAVE A RIGHT TO
SPEAK THEIR MIND.
THIS IS THE CORE OF THE AMERICAN
EXPERIMENT, GOVERNMENT IS THERE
TO PROTECT YOUR RIGHTS, NOT TO
TELL YOU WHAT YOU CAN STAND WHEN
YOU CAN SAY IT, AND LANDMARK
LAWSUIT, GOING DIRECTLY AFTER
THE COLLUSION, THEY ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO SUPPRESS SPEECH AND
WE ARE FIGHTING BACK.
>> Tucker: AS A CONSTITUTIONAL
MATTER, GOVERNMENT CANNOT
ENCOURAGE CENSORSHIP.
WE KNOW THAT THROUGH THE
SUPREME COURT, MANY RULINGS OVER
THE YEARS, VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, CORRECT?
>> YEP, THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT WE ARE ARGUING IN THIS CASE
IS THERE OUTSOURCING THAT.
THE GOVERNMENT IS OUTSOURCING
THE CENSORSHIP TO THE BIG TECH
PARTNERS, FLAGGING IT, AND BY
THE WAY THEY ARE TERRIFIED.
WE GET INTO DISCOVERY AND FIND
OUT HOW JEN PSAKI AND FAUCI AND
MARY POPPINS HERE ARE WORKING
WITH THE BIG TECH PARTNERS, WHAT
THEY ARE ASKING AND WILLING TO
TAKE DOWN.
WE KNOW IT IS THE LAPTOP FROM
HELL, THE ORIGINS OF COVID, WE
KNOW IT IS THE INEFFECTIVENESS
OF MASKS, WE KNOW ALL OF THESE
THINGS THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM ON IN THIS LAWSUIT
WILL HELP BRING THOSE TO
LIGHT AND EXPOSED IT AND THAT IS
WHY IT I